bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france le directeur
général de la police nationale frédéric
veaux a mis en avant le devoir de
réserve il estime aussi que cette
pétition fragilise
l'institution est ce que vous partager
ce sentiment bonsoir une petite
précision petit préalable du pays n'est
pas un syndicat c'est une association de
policiers indépendant qui n'est
d'ailleurs de façon totalement je dirais
en marge des syndicats suite aux
agressions de viry-châtillon donc je ne
porte pas la parole d'une institution
policière classique d'un syndicat et et
encore moins du ministère de l'intérieur
pardon vous faites bien de rectifier
c'est entendu merci voilà c'était juste
un petit un petit préalable qu'en penser
mais je pense que c'est dans l'air du
temps
vous savez l'institution policière n'est
plus du tout respectée dans ce pays
c'est un cri de colère on est six ans a
décrit colère qui vient d'horizons très
divers mais qui en même temps dans le
même sens ça dans le sens de la volonté
du retour à une normalité un respect des
institutions qui défendent ce pays que
cela plaise ou pas aux politiques
ensuite que le directeur général
s'exprime par rapport à cette expression
c'est très bien sauf que ce serait quand
même pas mal qui soutiennent aussi ces
hommes et ces hommes et ces femmes qui
tous les jours ils risquent leur vie
pour protéger justement la citoyenneté
de ce pays il faut pas toujours pas
regarder le doigt
qui montre la lune faut regarder la lune
il faut regarder ce qui se passe il faut
regarder ce qui motive tout ça est ce
qui motive tout ça c'est une
déliquescence absolue du respect de
cette institution politique donc c'est
un cri de colère
c'est un cri de colère que certains
estimeront baladoir maladroit
inappropriée peut-être je ne sais pas
c'est pas à moi d'en juger mais c'est
l'expression d'une colère il va falloir
quand même en tenir compte
si on ne veut pas que que tout se délite
vous savez ce cri de colère il était
poussé par d'autre part les militaires
hier par des policiers aujourd'hui mais
il peut tout aussi bien être poussé les
régulièrement par les personnels
soignants des institutions hospitalières
qui connaissent des difficultés tout à
fait comparable donc justifier cette
pétition est ce que la france traverse
selon vous une situation gravissime en
matière de sécurité pour reprendre les
termes qui sont employés vous savez il
faudrait vraiment habitée sur la planète
mars pour ne pas s'en rendre compte
bien sûr qu'il ya une situation qui est
en pleine déliquescence
si on voulait que l'institution ne se
rappelle pas par des moyens divers et
variés il eût fallu un quart moment
donné le politique soit la hauteur de la
situation et ça ne ce n'est pas avec des
positions à l'emporte-pièce à géométrie
variable que l'on provoque ce respect il
ya eu des comportements parfaitement
inadmissible et des discours
complètement d inappropriée je pense
notamment à la prise de position de
christophe castaner lorsque ces derniers
parlent et de se mettre à genoux dans un
élan compassionnel qui ne concernait
absolument pas la france nous avons des
prises de positions compassionnel dans
des périodes gravissime de meurtre de
fonctionnaires de police et là il va
bien falloir que gérald darmanin dépasse
la simple hobby la simple parole ou la
simple attitude est d'ailleurs cette
remarque vaut tout autant pour le
premier ministre que pour le président
de la république qui sont qui sont à
l'évidence dans la dans la posture et
qui ne prennent pas la mesure de ce qui
se passe dans ce pays
nous en tant qu'association nous avons
réglé avec depuis très longtemps à ce
que l'on revienne à des respects à les
respects aux respects de l'essentiel
et au respect tout simplement de la loi
donc on applique par exemple des mesures
simples qui aurait ignoré des réformes
simples à prendre notamment pour élargir
la capacité d'accueil dans les prisons
créer des prisons départemental par
exemple augmenter très largement c'est
le capacité d'accueil on ferait aussi
réfléchir et pourtant pas au cumul des
mandats et au cumul pardon des peines et
non plus par exemple simplement à la
confusion des peines vous savez s'il ya
un délinquant petit réitérant risques et
non pas simplement pour dix cambriolages
l'équivalent d'une peine correspondant à
1 mais au cumul des dix ça le ferait
fait réfléchir plus qu'il ya des peines
beaucoup plus lourde pour chaque lot
pour chaque infraction commise
donc il ya des pistes de réflexion qui
sont qui sont amenés mais il faut pour
cela sortir du quant-à-soi sortir de la
posture je le dis je le répète et au
lieu de ceux de se focaliser sur les
gens d'ederson les anciens
fonctionnaires de police ou les
fonctionnaires toujours en poste qui
s'exprime
il faut réfléchir la raison qui les
amène à s'exprimer oui il y avait péril
en la demeure oui il ya le feu à la
maison
il faut que nos politiques qui sont si
vaillant devant les postes télé ou
devant les caméras soient un peu plus
vaillants dans les actes dans les lois
qu'ils proposent et pas simplement
notamment de proposer des votes deux
lois déjà existantes ou de lancer des
idées assez farfelues sur la création de
services qui sont déjà existants je ris
personne en particulier mais bien une
idée de qui je veux parler
la parole se libère visiblement les
revendications sont très fortes les
officiers de police
comme les militaires finalement
aujourd'hui ont moins peur de prendre à
partie du gouvernement de dire ce qui ne
va pas très chère madame pas simplement
les officiers tous les corps de métier
et vous a pas échappé que sur la liste
des dessinateurs il ya des commissaires
les officiers mais aussi des des gens du
coin
d'applications gardiens de la paix
brigadier et dont on va dire de tous
grades
oui la parole doit se libérer si tu
libères aussi tout simplement parce que
la base ne se sentent plus représentés
comme elle le devrait
par des organisations syndicales qu'elle
estime trop molle dans ses positions
dans ses prises de position elle estime
qu'elle recule trop facilement dès lors
que l'administration on va dire le
politique lâche quelques bribes quelques
miettes pour stopper des négociations
oui il ya un vrai malaise est donc une
vraie volonté de faire entendre sa voix
au delà
au delà des cadres qu'on considère comme
étant assis fusionnelle comme les
syndicats ou les partis politiques
encore plus des partis politiques sont
parfaitement qui nous dit dans la
matière car malheureusement bien souvent
des politiques ignorent tout de ce qui
est réellement l'institution police
merci beaucoup à jean pierre colombier
est d'avoir pris le temps de réagir ce
soir sur la défense je rappelle que vous
êtes porte parole de l'association
deux policiers du pays